Emails are essential in business and everyday life.
Once you understand the basics of email, you
can communicate with people across the world.
Here are some tips to get you started.
Every email address contains an @ sign.
They can also appear in a number of different
formats.
For example, in the address john.smith@britishcouncil.org,
John Smith uses both his first name and surname.
His email comes from the British Council,
and the domain name ‘.org’ shows he is
part of an organisation.
In this example, Ahmed only uses his first
name in his address.
Yahoo is his email provider, and the domain
name “.bh” shows that the address is from
Bahrain.
Email addresses often include the name of
the country that the address is from.
An address from Afghanistan might end with
.af, an address from Sweden might end with
.se, and an address from Morocco might end
in .ma.
Some emails won’t feature a name at all.
Instead, many emails from companies use a
department title.
In the email address “reservations@beachhotelsbern.com”,
the first part of the address shows the message
is from the reservations department, while
the second part shows the name of the hotel
and that they are a company.
Another point to note is that some email addresses
will also use this symbol, known as an underscore.
It is used to separate parts of a name, much
like a dot.
It’s also not necessary to use capital J
and S in John Smith's email address.
People sometimes write email addresses with
capital initial letters.
Sometimes it’s all in capitals.
However, most people write email addresses
without capital letters.
Subscribe to our channel for more videos on
how to improve your English language skills.